so you mentioned surprising
being a characteristic of uh creativity
is there something
you already mentioned a few examples but
is there something that jumps out at you
as was particularly surprising
from the various evolutionary
computation systems you've worked on the
solutions that were
come up along the way not necessarily
the final solutions but
maybe things that even discarded is
there something that just jumps to mind
it it happens all the time i mean
evolution is so
creative uh so good at discovering
uh solutions you don't anticipate a lot
of times they are
taking advantage of something that you
didn't think was there like a bug in the
software for instance
a lot of there's a great paper uh the
community put it together
about uh surprising anecdotes about
evolution computation
a lot of them are indeed in some
software environment there was a
loophole or a bug and the system
utilizes that
by the way for people who want to read
it it's kind of fun to read it's
called the surprising creativity of
digital evolution a collection of
anecdotes from the evolutionary
computation and
artificial life research communities and
there's just a bunch of stories from
all the seminal figures in this
community uh you have a story in there
uh that released to you at least on the
tic-tac-toe memory bomb
so can you can you uh i guess uh
describe that situation if you think
that's yeah
that was that's a quite a bit smaller
scale than our um
basil doesn't need to sleep surprise but
but it was actually done by students in
my class
um in a neural net evolution computation
class
there was an assignment uh it was
perhaps a final project where
people built game playing uh ai
it was an ai class uh and this one and
and
it was for tic-tac-toe or five in a row
in a large board
and this one team evolved a neural
network
to make these moves uh and um they set
it up the evolution they didn't really
know what would come out
but it turned out that they did really
well evolution actually won the
tournament
and most of the time when it won it won
because the other teams
crashed and then when we look at it like
what was going on
was that evolution discovered that if it
makes a move that's really really far
away
like millions of squares away
the other teams the other programs just
expanded memory
in order to take that into account until
they ran out of memory and crashed
and then you win a tournament by
crushing all your opponents i think
that's
quite a profound example which
probably applies to most games
from even a game theoretic perspective
that sometimes to win you don't have to
be
better within the rules of the game you
have to come up with ways to
break your opponent's uh
brain if it's a human like not through
violence but through
some hack where the brain just is not um
you're basically uh how would you put it
you're
the you're going outside the constraints
of where the brain is able to
to function expectations of your
opponent i mean yeah this was even
kasparov pointed that out that when deep
blue was playing against kasparov that
it was not playing
the same way as kasparov expected and
this has to do with you know being not
having the same biases
uh and that's that's really one of the
strengths
of the ai approach
you